entre berri et auvergne à 450 mètres
d'altitude
voici guéret deux collines l'une
charmante l'autre sauvage se répondaient
de chaque côté de la ville à l'est
legault dit à l'ouest le mot cuit un
plateau désert avec ses landes
ces rochers c'est marcel jouhandeau
décrivant son guéret natale matériel
nabeul s'il en fût lapierre orientale le
destin des hommes de ce pays creusois
vers le métier de bâtisseur
c'est encore marcel jouhandeau qui nous
parle de sa ville sur chaque place la
musique de fontaine nous accueillir
comme celle d'un gros lot
depuis le xiiie siècle la fortune de la
ville de guéret lui va toujours de son
rôle administratif
elle devint la capitale de la haute
marche et d'une partie de la basse
marche la révolution l'a confirmé dans
ce rôle de chef lieu de circonscription
du 15e siècle le château des comtes de
la marche avec sa façade percée de
fenêtres à croisillons qui se dressent
dans le parc de la préfecture
c'est dans cette vaste salle aux murs
épais que le conseil général de la
creuse se réunit au mur des tapisseries
d'aubusson signée jean picart le doux
au dossier de chaque siège
les armes du canton en tapisserie
d'aubusson cette salle du conseil
général de guéret est une des plus
belles et des plus riches de france
les jardins de l'ancien hôtel de la
sénatorerie de l'image offre des étoiles
le calme et la fraîcheur de leur ombrage
l hôtel du xviiie siècle abrite quant à
lui un musée
sans entrer dans le détail 10 ont
toutefois que ce musée comporte 18
salles il est classé parmi les plus
beaux de province
sûrs d'eux funéraire fier silex armes
costumes et surtout une inattendue
section de zoologie qui apprend aux
petits guérétois les animaux du monde
il
depuis dix ans le tir aux pigeons de
guéret rassemble les meilleurs fusils de
la région chaque année lors des concours
régionaux de nombreuses coupes
reviennent tous tireur guérétois le tir
au pigeon d'argile ball trap recueil
d'année en année de plus en plus
d'adeptes loisirs et sports le tir aux
pigeons et les deux à la fois il fait
appel à l'adresse du terreur tout autant
qu'à ses réflexes c'est de toute manière
un excellent entraînement pour la
science
leur pays et si aimablement variés que
nombreux sont les guérétois qui aiment
voir d'en haut toutes les subtilités et
l'harmonie du bocage marchois pour cela
guéret dispose d'un aéroclub ordinale
cinq appareils
une soixantaine de membres enthousiaste
et qui savent communiquer à leurs
concitoyens les plaisirs du classement
souvent ici en pays creusois les
rivières prennent des allures de temps
les eaux vives
l'air est fraîche disputent le lit des
rivières à d'énormes rochers vestiges du
gigantesque spasmes géologique qui agite
à la montagne à l'aube des séries hier à
l'air qui est sinueuse se prête tout
naturellement à la pratique du sport
très spectaculaire
le canoë kayak
un village une église une statue un nom
un même souvenir bourde en bourde en fut
le pseudonyme qu'emprunta pierre
mailloux se creusois qui allait devenir
au micro de radio londres
pierre bourdan le porte-parole des
français ni le sport équestre et le
saviez vous la forme de tourisme qui se
développe le plus rapidement en france
comment ne pas imaginer alors que le
sport équestre
n'allez pas trouver un terrain
d'élection dans cette région de forêts
de lacs et de rivières à distance
à langer juste pour gagner au jeu soit
mamans allaitant chez vous bien le mans
et rennes bien ajuster les gens près du
chemin doucement doucement doucement sur
la dore doucement mais c'est les mains
sur la norme
e
le syndicat d'initiative de guéret a
lancé un slogan bien sympathique
en creuse vacances vise guéret met à
votre disposition ses 19 hôtels et 80 de
meublés
et si vous décidez de passer vos
vacances entre eux soupçonnent ces
cavaliers rien ne vous empêchera au
hasard de galop de vous prendre pour
d'artagnan glenn ford et autres john
wayne
oui mais